all right let's have some fun we've
talked before about how Donald Trump's
English language skills aren't the best
Donald Trump is a native English speaker
Donald Trump doesn't speak any other
language that I'm aware of but he
doesn't read period his reading
comprehension as a result is visibly
compromised when he has to read anything
other than the sort of latest material
we all know that that's not new
yesterday Donald Trump met with French
president Emmanuel macron on the
sidelines or I guess we would say in
advance of the NATO summit that's taking
place in the United Kingdom and I
realized when I was watching the video
McCrone can better express himself in
English which is Trump's native and only
language and not the native language for
Emmanuel macron then Donald Trump
himself can express himself so I'm not
literally saying McCrone speaks better
English than Trump I am saying Makram
seems to be better able to do sort of
hypothetical multi-dimensional thinking
out loud than Donald Trump McCrone is
better able to express ideas in more
nuanced ways than Donald Trump
even in his non-native language of
English in this video you are going to
see Donald Trump first talk about
capturing Isis fighters in Syria sort of
stumbling around it's unclear what point
Trump is tank trying to make at one
point he asks McCrone hey do you want
some nice Isis fighters it's all very
weird it's not making any sense and then
you'll see the French president take
control of the situation
taking talking more seriously about the
reality that despite what Donald Trump
might say Isis has not been defeated and
you will see that even in the English as
a second language spoken by a Manuel
McCrone he elucidates more
thoughtfulness and nuance than Donald
Trump could ever hope to when talking
about this issue let's take a look if
you're watching you will notice Trump
doing this thing where when Trump feels
emasculated or upset at what someone
next to him is saying or doing
he will sort of look down and have a
particular look on his face you're going
to see Trump do it and then after Donald
Trump
when Donald Trump gets a chance to talk
again he has nothing left to do but to
just attack McCrone by calling it a
non-answer merely because Donald Trump
doesn't like it let's take a look a lot
to find and see in this clip we have a
tremendous amount of captured fighters
Isis fighters over in Syria and they're
all under lock and key but many are from
France many are from Germany many of
them UK they're mostly from Europe and
some of the countries are agreeing I
have not spoken to the president about
that would you like some nice Isis
fighters yeah I could give them Cuba
pigging you can take everyone you want
let's be serious a very large number of
fighters you have underground a
scientist coming from Syria for me right
foreign fighters coming from Europe but
the tiny minority all of them we have in
the region and I think number-one
priority because it's not yet finished
its to get rid of Isis and this always
works this is our number-one priority
and it's not yet done I'm sorry to say
that yes you still have fighters in this
region in Syria and now in Iraq and more
and more and the oldest stabilization of
the region makes the situation more
difficult to fix the situation against
Isis secondly some of these foreign
fighters are being killed in Iraq
because of the deeds precisely they
acted in this very region and we would
have a case-by-case option we have a
humanitarian approach for children
already organized and we will have the
case-by-case approach but for me the
very first objectives in the region is
to finish war against Isis and and and
don't don't make any mistake your number
one problem are most foreign fighters
this is the Isis fighters
and you have more more than fighters due
to the situation today this is why he's
a great politician because that was one
of the greatest non answers okay you can
tell that when Donald Trump isn't
pleased and he feels emasculated he does
that thing where he looks down at the
ground while the other person is talking
and then of course Trump just has to
attack McCrone rather than addressing
the substance which he either didn't
understand or probably wasn't listening
to because McCrone didn't talk for
ninety straight seconds there once again
we started the show today with Donald
Trump being the embarrassment that he is
and being made fun of by world leaders
video of Emmanuel macron and Boris
Johnson and Justin Trudeau is laughing
at Trump because Trump is literally the
laughingstock of the world right now and
it's embarrassing and it's sad and here
it is once again Donald Trump
embarrassing the United States on the
world stage getting called out on his
lies in real time by the French
president Emmanuel macron but it's not
going to hurt Trump very much because
trumpets will see this they'll also zone
out during those 90 seconds that McCrone
is speaking they will just see Trump say
look at that non-answer comment and
think wow what is zinger Trump really
got him
Trump is strong and Trump won can you
imagine would you like some nice Isis
fighters Trump asks McCrone when you see
Trump sitting next to real diplomats
like a Manuel McCrone doesn't mean you
agree with everything McCrone stands for
or his policy or whatever but when you
see Trump next to a real diplomat it
shows you how in over his head Donald
Trump is particularly at these
international events sometimes to
Americans when Trump is with a world
leader who doesn't speak English and you
have to go through live translation the
difference in intelligence in knowledge
intact in cleverness it's not noticeable
because of that language barrier because
of the fact that we're going through
live translation to hear what the other
world leader is saying when the other
world leader speaks English even
accented English learned as a second
language as is the case with the French
president the credibility gap the
critical thinking
the knowledge gap it becomes unavoidably
clear and that's what happened there in
that video Trump totally out of his
element
Trump totally out of his League and the
next question is what will come of the
NATO summit in the UK and I got a lot of
emails about this by the time you listen
to today's show or watch clips from
today's show we may know what the
dynamic was at the main meetings of the
NATO summit of course it's five six
hours ahead of the East Coast there in
the UK and as I mentioned earlier a lot
of caution being taken to prevent Donald
Trump from just ruining the meetings
Donald Trump has been very critical even
coming from a place of ignorance but
very critical of the relationship of
different countries to NATO of NATO in
and of itself as I mentioned earlier
Emmanuel macron playing a little bit of
toddler reverse psychology with Donald
Trump and getting Donald Trump to defend
NATO merely by making sort of narrow and
specific critique of NATO there is fear
there is fear among Trump staffers and
among other world leaders and their
staffers of what is Donald Trump's
presence at this summit going to do we
will cover it tomorrow we will see
ultimately what comes of it let me know
what you predict will happen maybe
you'll already know by the time today's
episode is published we'll talk about it
more tomorrow the next video is coming
soon but before you go to that please
hit subscribe and like we're running a
test we believe that if everybody does
this this will hugely boost us in
YouTube's algorithm and then everybody
wins I'll report back to you how this
works make sure before you go on to that
next video hit subscribe hit like thank
you so much